en estas imágenes publicadas por el
ministerio de defensa ruso se muestran
camiones militares cruzando el puente de
crimea aparentemente abandonando la
península del mar negro moscú dice que
es parte del retorno de las fuerzas a
sus bases permanentes pero no es
suficiente para convencer a los aliados
occidentales
hemos escuchado las señales de moscú
sobre la voluntad de continuar los
esfuerzos diplomáticos pero hasta ahora
no hemos visto ninguna desescalada sobre
el terreno por el contrario parece que
rusia continúa con la concentración
militar
contingente militar y boudou a pesar de
que rusia ha anunciado la retirada de
sus tropas de la frontera ucraniana la
otan dijo que se había preparada para lo
peor el presidente ruso vladimir putin
señaló que quería una vía diplomática
para salir de la crisis diciendo que
moscú no quiere una guerra con europa la
unión europea sin embargo se ha hecho
eco de los llamamientos a una
desescalada concreta
ayer rusia envió ciertamente señales
contradictorias por un lado las
autoridades anunciaron la retirada de
las tropas rusas por otro la duma bota
el reconocimiento formal de dones y
logan's como repúblicas independientes
publix el martes la duma la cámara baja
del parlamento ruso esto a putin a
reconocer la independencia de dos
regiones separatistas respaldadas por
rusia en el este de ucrania la medida
anularía en gran medida los protocolos
de mainz firmados por moscú y kiev en
2014 y 2015 aunque los acuerdos nunca se
aplicaron en su totalidad garantizaban
que las regiones seguirían formando
parte de ucrania el canciller alemán
olaf scholz dijo que sería un desastre
político si el kremlin firmara el
reconocimiento